I honestly believe that I will never
regret choosing not to have children
it's potentially the biggest decision
you'll ever have to make we are not
allowed to say that motherhood is boring
but what if like me being a parent is
something you're just not sure about I
think within particular cultures that it
really is a big thing I think this
status involved in being a mother global
fertility rates have almost half since
1950 and the world could be facing a
baby bust if people don't want to have
children
that is if people don't think that our
society is worth perpetuating what if we
got wrong with my future happiness on
the line and my body clock ticking what
are my options unhappy that my children
are alive but read surprised I had to
pay in order to raise them
every year roughly a hundred and thirty
million people are added to the Earth's
population and as a woman in my late
twenties good job happy relationship
living in London I feel like I'm under
enormous pressure to be adding to that
total my children certainly make me very
happy it makes me so happy happy in so
many different ways I can genuinely say
absolutely super happy as a mum I
I think for me the thing is that you're
just giving yourself to something beyond
yourself it's a different kind of fun
now and I had a lot of the other kind of
fun in my 20s early 30s definitely more
meaningful your life is for that I'm not
saying that it's not struggle I'm not
saying it's not hard I'm not saying that
it's like really ups and this really bad
low sometimes but I think that's with
anything in life whether you've got
children or you don't have children you
go through one of those struggles anyway
so but with children I think it's
amazing happy parents might say one
thing how about those closest to me I
right now really don't have to decide to
have children and whenever I picture my
future I always be myself Jude you have
never been asked what's your choice are
you going are you going to have children
or are you not know it's always been
well it's always been when wet my mum
will call me in an arrest when you can
have a baby again you're mine and I'll
yell all the time stop when I get the
hat out of the box and when are we
having a great grandchild yeah good luck
I'm very aware of my body clock it
completely makes difference where you
are cuz I've got friends up north are
all married and settle down and kids is
like very much on the agenda and it's
good done things I think have always
known lively children but I also have a
career that I love and I'm just I'm just
not ready for it it's a real luxury job
to do just what you know just be a
parent
but I think that's the thing it's just
not possible to have to have it all
clearly not everyone feels the same I'm
only one tiny part of a hugely diverse
population the speaking to my best
friend has got me thinking what if I
don't ever want to have children but
surely I'm not the only one who has
asked that question reading around
clearly not I found an article written
by journalist Holly Brockwell in 2015
describing how she was finding it hard
to get sterilized as a woman in her 20s
usually if I say I don't want kids the
first question is why not that it's said
in a tone of voice that means why would
you possibly not want this thing you
know kind of what's wrong with you you
don't get people saying we're trying for
children and people go but why the first
few times I asked about sterilization it
was pretty much like I said I wanted to
grow a second head
the doctors male and female just looked
at me like I was completely bonkers like
they'd never been asked this before ever
and as if there was no hope in hell of
me ever getting that done not just at
the age of 26 as I was then
but into my 30s it took four years from
when I first asked to when I was able to
actually get my suicide and even then it
felt like it was touch and go like it
could revoke permission at anytime it
was really scary and I think the hardest
thing through that entire time was that
I got pregnant accidentally I'd done
everything right contraceptive wise and
it just happened anyway as it does I
guess to some people and it was
particularly frustrating for me because
I felt like if they just listened to me
the first 10 times the first 15 times
but asked for this procedure I would not
have had to go through the absolutely
miserable experience that I did in the
end I had a miscarriage natural
miscarriage quite early on which I guess
you could say was lucky but it just felt
awful
[Music]
it felt like I'd wished this child out
of existence like I thought I'd done
something to my body that made it feel
unwelcome and from my experience with
feeling not wanted by my mum I felt
awful about that one of the things that
plays on my mind is the ticking of the
dreaded biological clock women are born
with a fixed number of eggs in their
ovaries normally around 2 million by the
age of 37
there's only 25,000 left it means I
don't have that much longer to make my
decision but unlike women who had to
fight for the right to even vote all
those who had to fulfil the
stereotypical gender role or even those
who finally found a sense of sexual
liberation we have never had it so good
and I'm just not sure I'm willing to
give some of it up yet that could be a
factor in why globally fertility rates
are falling
technically that means the number of
children born for every woman of
childbearing age and a population is
going down jargon aside the reality is
that nearly half of all countries are
facing a baby bust and an aging
population people's ideal life people's
sense of what would the good life look
like still basically means getting
married having kids
maybe housing has gotten more expensive
maybe child cares gotten more expensive
maybe it's not barriers maybe it's just
competing aspirations that people
continue to say that you know 2.5
children and a spouse would be ideal but
there are a lot of other great things
out there in the world that weren't
there in the past but what we really see
is that the determinative factor is
marriage when people change how long
they wait to get married
fertility changes correspondingly
children make people happy period the
issue is that having children makes
people happy paying for children does
not make people
[Music]
and pay new will being a parent costs an
average of a hundred and fifty thousand
seven hundred and fifty three pounds to
bring up your child to the age of
eighteen for a couple and 183 thousand
three hundred and thirty five if you're
a single parent another of my main
concerns is the state of the world which
my potential child would grow up in and
it turns out giving birth is the most
destructive thing a person can do to the
planet one child it was about sixty tons
of co2 equivalent emissions every year
that's worse than eating meat driving a
car or traveling by plane and even if I
got over all of that and was lucky
enough to get pregnant a child won't
necessarily bring me happiness one study
has even suggested that the happiest
part of the population is unmarried
child free women me then but it's not as
simple as that
depending on your culture religion
upbringing background you might have
very different pressures put on you as a
potential parent asthma and Vanessa are
both mums now but felt pressure from
their communities when they were trying
to get pregnant there's almost like a
silent time constraint they put on
married couples I think within people
probably if as soon as you go down the
aisle back down the aisle you're married
they really start looking down see if
you're pregnant
it's very pronatalist a very pronounced
illest community in terms of the black
community with women I think there's
just this belief is that it's almost
like it goes in stages there's almost an
expectation that you'll obviously go
through higher education or go through
university get a good job next thing is
get married and then also have kids and
I think what's missing from that is that
isn't so plain failing with every couple
so I think within particular cultures
that it really is a big thing I think
the status involved in being the mother
we had been married for two years of
that Damon and people's expectation was
you know when you having kids you don't
want kids is that because you're working
is that because you're too busy and so
forth and afar suggester I shrug it off
and you think you know it's a stone - my
husband and I
trying and you know it's just it's not
happening but the more you hear from
people and then you see family members
with kids as well and it really really
starts to hit home I wanted to speak to
someone who has had children and now
questions that decision having children
means less opportunity less fun less
freedom less money less sex Greene mayor
has written a book called no kids 40
good reasons not to have children and it
contains chapters like the parents worst
nightmares and York it will always
disappoint me I'm a quite happy person
by my own so I know where my happiness
is and I don't need others to find it in
fact I didn't need my children to find
happiness and now that they they are
grownups I'm a quite happy person I
don't see them very often and I think
it's great that I have this problem I
know where my freedom is having to care
for people is a huge burden a more
selfish and I'm very proud to say that
being selfish sometimes is a it's a very
good thing to be honest I found what
Kareem said really refreshing she was
completely honest about what she wanted
to do and not what was expected of her
but to be a child of someone who Gretz
you is far from easy
my mum has been pretty open and vocal
about the fact that she didn't want
children she said she never wanted them
she's basically regretted it ever since
which I understand on a logical level
isn't my fault but on an emotional level
it does feel sometimes like you should
apologize for existing I do feel guilty
for all the things she hasn't been able
to do with all the dreams she hasn't
been able to chase but at the same time
I kind of feel like well if that's the
decision you make you have to live with
it and in my case I want to make sure
that's not the decision
don't have to live with it there are
plenty of people out there living with
it
I found a Facebook group called I regret
having children that describes itself as
a support group for overwhelmed parents
over 13,000 people like the page some of
the anonymous posts are pretty
heart-wrenching it made me realize how
many people could avoid all that pain
and sadness by just being able to say I
don't want kids without any fear of
judgment people really see it as an
unnatural thing as something that's
against nature something that you
shouldn't feel and I think it's really
dangerous when you start telling people
what they shouldn't feel and what they
shouldn't do with their own bodies there
are many reasons why a person might not
want to have a child or may not be able
to have a child and I don't think we
should pressure people I think rather we
as a society have to do some
introspection if people don't want to
have children that is if people don't
think that our society is worth
perpetuating what have we done wrong so
I don't feel that much closer to being
able to make a decision about whether or
not I should try the kids do I take a
chance that I'll develop those feelings
of patience and selflessness that are so
important to being a good parent do I
wait until the time's right for me and
just hope that my body's up to the task
or do I say go for it now's the time and
just hope that I'm not one of those
parents who live to regret it when your
children are Werner's you don't
recognize at all the reason why you you
had them because they are so different
than what you expected which you dreamed
it can be a good surprise but it can be
bad surprise you never know perhaps I
was a bit naive in thinking that I
wouldn't get that much back I would
supposed to be getting support from
people in the same situation that was
not the case the stigma around not
having kids it seems to fall entirely on
women
and I think it's because it plays into
some ancient obsolete nonsense gender
role around being a mother and that
being why you're on earth and it being
the point of your life and I think if
people find fulfillment in it that's
wonderful but I don't think women who
have kids are in any way just mothers
and just parents that was one of the
biggest voices of the community that I
had to hear from people oh it's all her
fault
and she can't have kids you know that's
what happens when you get married later
in life and that's what happens when you
have a kid here you don't want a case
and so forth and I thought well and
everyone's so quick to blame a female
what I do know is that regardless of
your upbringing your background your
culture your family you should feel
empowered to make that decision about
whether or not you should reproduce not
feel obliged and I think we as a society
need to get a whole lot more accepting
of those who decide not to have children